[Music]
at the beginning of september the mcu
blockbuster xiangxi and the legend of
the 10 rings was released in theaters
and you can now also watch it on disney
plus the story revolves around the
martial arts master shanxi who has to
deal with the mysterious organization of
the 10 rings and at the same time has to
face his own past the movie grossed
almost
432 million us dollars worldwide which
is not a bad result in times of a
pandemic as the us magazine deadline
revealed a few days ago there is an
exclusive contract between shangshi
director destin daniel [ __ ] and disney
accordingly [ __ ] will not only take
care of his sequel but also develop a
disney plus series of his own clever
viewers of xiangxi may have an idea who
this series will revolve around namely
xia ling shown in the post-credits scene
who is the protagonist's sister the
contract between kravn and disney is
expected to run for several years and in
addition to the mcu project will also
include other productions by the 43 year
old on the hulu streaming service
unfortunately nothing is known about the
plot of changshi 2 at the moment but we
will of course keep you up to date
sony pictures of venom let there be
carnage hit theaters on october 1st in
the united states despite the low age
rating and the comparatively short
running time of 97 minutes the
blockbuster turned out to be a success
with worldwide box office takings of
over 480 million us dollars
unsurprisingly executive producer amy
pascal has now already announced the
third installment in the venom franchise
according to the interview that the
producer gave to the us magazine
collider she spoke of venom 3 already
being in the early planning stages so
good news for fans of eddie brock and
his inseparable symbiote friend
currently however all the capacities are
focused on spiderman no way home as the
release date on december 17th is
imminent and will be groundbreaking for
further films of the mcu as usual
additional information has been withheld
but it can be assumed that we won't see
eddie brock and the big screen again
until 2023 at the earliest
the shazam spin-off black adam will
debut in theaters next summer as main
actor dwayne johnson announced in an
exclusive story there will be a big
fight between black adam and superman in
the foreseeable future he said that he
doesn't know which superman it will be
or who will play him but he's very sure
that sooner or later they will clash
meanwhile total film revealed the first
images of dwayne johnson in his new
costume after we have only seen concept
art in the past the suit could not be
more fitting and is bursting with the
details including an ancient cuny form
which of course alludes to the dc
villain's historical past the pictures
are definitely worth a look and make us
wait all the more eagerly for a first
trailer black adam will be released on
july 29th 2022
the third and final film of the jurassic
world trilogy will be released in the
summer of next year the movie will be
about a new age which of course also
includes new dinosaurs an image taken
directly from the scene in the new film
shows one such creature or at least you
can sort of see it behind bryce delos
howard who's in the water you can see
dinosaur with amazingly long claws as
director colin trevorrow confirmed on
twitter the creature is indeed a
therazinozarus what makes it special is
its comparatively odd appearance marked
by its long claws and even longer arms
the depiction in the upcoming movie is
also exciting on a scientific level as
no skull has yet been found of the
dinosaur that is native to mongolia
therefore a classification to carnivores
or herbivores is not really possible and
accordingly it is not known whether he
will specifically hunt humans either way
it is an exciting new arrival we look
forward to more new images of jurassic
world dominion which is scheduled for
release on june 10th 2020 2022
in less than a year the first sequel to
the most successful film of all time
will be released we're of course talking
about avatar 2. the anticipation of a
reunion with pandora and the navi after
a remarkable 12 year break is
correspondingly great producer john
landau provided some deeper insights
into the production in an interview with
total film magazine for instance the
saudis are no longer in the familiar
environment as we know it and also the
offspring was not long incoming as we
already know from several photos avatar
2 is supposed to focus on the enchanting
underwater world of pandora where by the
way we make acquaintance with the water
people of the met kaena who are new to
the audience the motivation for the
escape into the wet is the incessant
exploitation missions of the resource
development administration rda for short
which are making the most of the
valuable raw material on obtainium at
great expense lando also raved about
director james cameron who incorporated
many different themes that should appeal
to just about any viewer the central
aspect of the sequels continues to be
jake and ethere's young family however
in spite of the changing circumstances
thus in between action-packed sequences
there will be plenty of time to tell the
story of the sullies with all its ups
and downs in the upcoming three possibly
even four planned sequels the five part
story has been in mind for quite some
time anyway since all scripts had
already been complete before the first
camera start filming avatar 2 each with
its own climax of course further news
concerns a published picture of the
shooting director james cameron elite
actress and worthington can be seen in
good spirits on the set wedding the
abbot died for the elaborate produced
movie avatar 2 is scheduled for release
in theaters on december 16 2022
particularly during the christmas season
the harry potter film series enjoys
great popularity fittingly the 20th year
since the release of this sorcerer's
stone is approaching which is why warner
brothers revealed some details about the
upcoming anniversary this week powder
halves can look forward to two specials
which will appear on hbo max january 1st
2022 will be the day and we can look
forward to a long-awaited reunion of the
most important actors after all these
years in addition there will be an
exclusive making off on the sorcerer's
stone of course with none other than
director chris columbus himself this
will include in-depth interviews with
the actors and actresses first and
foremost of course with the trio daniel
radcliffe emma watson and rupert grind
here's what's special the actors now in
their early 30s have not been seen in
this constellation since harry potter
and the deathly hallows part 2 which is
why this event is something very special
for long time fans something else to
enjoy is harry potter hogwarts
tournament of houses which is a
four-part quiz show based around the
wizarding world led by helen mirren four
teams compete against each other to win
the house cup you can definitely look
forward to hundreds of questions and of
course some unexpected guests it
premiered on november 28th and you can
watch it on tbs as well as cartoon
network besides that the year 2022
already seems to be a great one for
potter hats especially since the spin
off fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore will be released on april
15th 2022
in an interview with cinema blend this
week marvel boss kevin feige dropped the
bombshell about daredevil which has been
up in the air for some time foggy made
it clear for him only charlie cox is an
option as a lead actor where how and
especially when that would happen the
president of marvel studios known for
his great secrecy of course did not want
to reveal especially fans of the netflix
series with charlie cox all likely to be
pleased after all the story around the
blind lawyer matt murdock and his
special abilities which he uses for good
thrilled many fans in a total of three
seasons the timing of the announcement
is to all appearances precisely
calculated since spider-man no way home
will be released next week where
possible appearance of daredevil has
been causing rumors to circulate for a
long time the version of daredevil that
charlie cox will then play in the mcu in
the future is quite likely to be
different from the one he held on
netflix events of three seasons will
therefore possibly be completely ignored
since the multiverse at least offers
enough possibilities for this what will
happen to the other actors from the
series and when daredevil will actually
return to the mcu remains to be seen in
any case we advise you to keep your eyes
open for spider-man no way home which
will be released next week
that's it with our news for this week if
you've already watched arcane on netflix
and want to hear some ideas regarding
the second season you should definitely
check out our latest original about
arcane 2. if you haven't seen it yet
also check out the new trailer for sonic
the hedgehog 2 on our channel an
absolute must for fans of lighting fast
hedgehog
[Music]
foreign
[Music]